Oh confession God right on the first one
you guys want me to get hey what's up
i'm bella thorne I'm with BuzzFeed and
we're playing questioning confession are
you guys ready for this confession I
have a fear of being alone um ever since
I got my nose piercing it's really hard
for me to pick my nose it is so
difficult I can't I can't get in there
it's so difficult and when I put it up
it just feels like I have a booger in my
nose so that like makes me want to pick
it even blue the last person I texted
and it's not just because this is about
famous and love is literally Carter
Jenkins from famous love because he just
landed in New York and he just asked me
what am i doing today
[Music]
man I just love them confessions oh I
hate mint gum anything mint like when I
brush my teeth I have to do with like
coconut oil because it's just I can't do
mint I've got a kissing scene with a guy
like don't you dare or a do face it's
the worst my mom tried to buy me down
when I was younger cuz you know I hate
men and I just you know I just never
brushed my teeth I'm really not hygienic
so do you miss working with zendaya and
do you solve a close relationship with
her yes I loves India and we are still
we are still friends and we do talk we
don't get to really hang out that much
because we're on such different
schedules all the time but when we do it
feels like we're still on shake it up
it's cool when you have friends like
that when you talk to and you're like
wow I feel like it's exactly the same
like we're still 14 shake it up dancing
our [ __ ] life away I never drink I
like don't do it not just because like
it's illegal and I'm like supposed to
say that I don't drink but like I just
don't drink I have a nipple piercing I
have a nose piercing I have all the rest
of them are on my ears like yeah like 18
piercings altogether
I mean pretty sure everybody already
knows about my nipple piercing so I
guess it's not really a confession but
no I don't have my vagina imperious if
that's what you're thinking what about
was going to be
you've inspired me to come out as
pansexual to many of my friends what's
it like to have an influence on so many
people when I read these kind of things
this is what makes me happy to do what I
do because you never know what kind of
impact you have on people and then I
read tweets like this I see things like
this and this is why I do what I do
especially on social media and famous
and love you play a girl suddenly thrust
into the limelight have you felt like
you have been what is the hardest part
of family I guess I wasn't the rust it
was like gently like crawled I guess you
could say but I think since I was 9 so
Abin at this for a good minute and the
hardest part about Fame is like if you
want to go out with your friends I'm
like you know you're you're you're
feeling frisky and you want to wear a
short skirt and you're like oh wow this
is you know this is scandalous you can't
because you will be judged by everybody
around the world calling you a [ __ ] and
that that sucks because I'm 19 and I
should be able to do whatever the [ __ ] I
want with my friends you know living a
life as a normal 19 year old but I don't
get to do that do you have any advice
for other young bisexual girls like me
maybe those who are fully or partially
in the closet still it is really hard to
give advice because you never know what
that certain person is going through
what their home like their home life is
and and everything else so if I were to
say anything I would just say that the
one thing I regret growing up was just
not being me and I spent so much of my
life not being me and like you never get
those years back so just be you and say
I am Who I am because who wants to be
anybody else
the shit's boring